[Music]  [Applause]  here's to hotel transylvania  johnny works so hard to make this extra  special  fire  [Music]  nice  ruined everything johnny what are you  talking about  your dad never really thought of me as  part of the family all because i'm not a  monster  so you want to become a monster huh van  helsing  the muncification ray turns humans into  monsters and monsters into humans but is  this safe though  great question  that's weird nothing happened  hey drac what's up johnny  [Music]  the nightmare it's over i'm human again  what's going on  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh  oh no you're a human and i'm a monster  we need to fix this now not the moment  away  oh  [Music]  [Music]  it's wondrous it's  burning my eyes  [Music]  you